[Music]
on this Saturday night the National
Guard moves in to quell the chaos the
riots and the rage overtakes several
states so let's be very clear the
situation in Minneapolis is no longer in
any way about the murder of George Floyd
what we know about George Floyd and the
former Minneapolis police officer
charged in his death the call for
answers in the death of a Toronto woman
she fell to her death after police were
called in to help what her family says
happened plus the debate over funding
the World Health Organization after the
u.s. pulls out god feed and the dragon
lists off what today is about is
reigniting the dream of space space
exploration is back in style
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
the fire and the fury in the streets of
Minneapolis overnight as violence broke
out during protests over the killing of
George Floyd the latest death of a black
American at the hands of police officers
has ignited uprisings in at least 30
states but the vandalism and clashes
with riot police have taken the
spotlight off the calls for racial
justice there are concerns the
destruction is being fueled by
instigators taking advantage of the
black community's grief and outrage in
Minneapolis the governor has called in
the National Guard so if you are on the
streets tonight it is very clear you are
not with us you do not share our values
and we will use the full strength of
goodness and righteousness to make sure
that this ends we'll take you to
Minnesota in a moment but first let's
take you to Washington DC where the
protests are picking up in the US
Capitol
Jackson we understand police have had to
use tear gas Robin they deployed pepper
spray actually a short time ago there's
essentially been a tense back-and-forth
here with the crowd so here's the
situation we are at a park that is
across the street from the White House
the park has been barricaded by police
but several times the protesters have
breached those temporary barricades at
some points some protesters have thrown
water bottles and rocks and Talisa fired
back small volleys of pepper spray at
certain times for the most part though
these protests are remaining peaceful
and in fact there are several protest
groups that have been moving throughout
washing washing today today a little bit
earlier this afternoon kind of gives you
a flavor what's going on
we saw protesters surround a Washington
DC police car the officer left there was
no real confrontation but then we saw
people start to to move into the park
and that's really what touched off this
confrontation we're seeing large police
movements throughout the city this
evening at this point and really the
question is where does this go from here
and I think Robin that's the question
that is being faced by many cities in
America tonight this is a very volatile
time in the US and the White House is in
lockdown with the president inside what
is his response Ben
in fact the president just returned to
the White House just in the past ten
minutes he's been in Florida all day for
the space launch there has sort of been
a tense messaging coming from the
president at one point today over
Twitter he actually suggested that his
supporters the mega crowd make America
great again should perhaps hold a
counter protest and Robin you know that
something like that would not go well
that would lead to further clashes that
counter protest did not materialize the
president though has also been in a
showdown with local officials here in
Washington DC suggesting that DC's mayor
is doing nothing to keep the White House
or city streets safe and that's simply
not true
DC's police are out here along with the
Secret Service are you getting a sense
that Secret Service is confronting the
protesters or vice versa like it was
last night they are doing their best I
think to hold the line when you look in
the park here those are parks police and
Secret Service and essentially what they
do is they're standing in formation in
right here they will give verbal
warnings when they want people to move
backwards they did several times before
they cleared the park they seem content
maintaining perimeter here outside the
park but we have seen Secret Service
step up their presence throughout the
day as well they've taken up positions
on top of several of the guard houses
inside the White House compound so that
they can have a better view of the
situation out here as it unfolds
Jackson Brasco in Washington these
protests are not just centered in
Minneapolis and Washington
demonstrations and riots are sweeping
across the u.s. Jennifer Johnson reports
Minneapolis was ablaze again overnight
as rage and riots overtook dozens of
American cities it's been hailed it's
been a war zone protesters demanding
justice after the police involved death
of George Floyd the now fired officer
Derek sha'ban showed on video kneeling
on ployed snack for almost nine minutes
has been charged with third degree
murder and second degree manslaughter
charges not harsh enough to quell this
fury Minnesota's governor calls Floyd's
death a murder but he is pleading for
calm last night is a mockery of
pretending this is about George Floyd's
death because our communities of color
and our indigenous communities were out
front fighting hand and hand to say
businesses that took generations to
build Floyd's family is demanding a
second independent autopsy after the
county's medical examiner pointed to
underlying health issues not
strangulation as the cause of death u.s.
president Donald Trump says the federal
government is ready to back up the state
National Guard's we have our military
ready willing and able today everyone at
: military authorities have not charged
the three other officers at the scene
although all were fired further fueling
charges of racism not only in
Minneapolis but across the country
people of color and black people
especially are not treated equal there's
so much racism in this country rioters
also took to the streets in dozens of
other cities in Atlanta landmarks
including the CNN center and the College
Football Hall of Fame were attacked this
is not a protest this is not in the
spirit of Martin Luther King jr. this is
chaos a federal protection officer was
shot and killed another injured after
shots rang out amid protests in Oakland
California the County Justice Center set
on fire in Portland Oregon
and an angry mob tried to get through a
barrier near the White House which had
to be put on lockdown
nighttime curfews are in place but are
being ignored looters outnumbering law
enforcement even some celebrities are
weighing in telling protesters to find
another way it is time to beat up
prosecutors you don't like it the voting
booth it is time to hold me oriole
Office is accountable volunteers are now
spending their weekend cleaning up the
destruction but protesters promised
another night of unrest unable to
control their anger after another
restrained black man died pleading for
his life Jennifer Johnson Global News
Washington let's take you to Minneapolis
now where the city is under a curfew but
that hasn't stopped the protesters the
governor admits the police can't control
the situation
NBC's Morgan Chesky is on the ground
there are Morgan what is the response to
the National Guard moving in the
response will be much more visible than
what we've seen in night's past but I do
want to make a very clear difference
between the protests that we've seen
during the day here in many
appleís and the activities by the masses
that have taken place at night and the
governor acknowledged that also saying
that 80% of the arrests that took place
in the early morning hours in today were
from people that were out of state and
so he was trying to draw that line as
these are as these people are here that
there's our peaceful there are peaceful
protests to be had and that are entirely
separate from the devastation and the
destruction that we've seen from those
groups of people that have moved in at
night and and essentially had free rein
in certain parts of the city because
police were not able to move in or
simply chose not to so with the arrival
of a thousand new National Guardsmen
today that should definitely change the
situation when that 8:00 p.m. curfew
goes into effect this evening however
any actual enforcement will have to wait
and see Robin Morgan is affair to say
that these protests have degenerated
into chaos I think it depends on what
protests we look at because during the
day protests such as this one have
existed in a very peaceful manner
beginning about a mile away from here
near the fifth Precinct police station
in Minneapolis before marching to this
intersection where we're out right now
and we're very close to where George
Floyd lost his life on Monday evening
and so right now crowds have been
keeping relatively peaceful however
we've seen the disintegration of
peaceful protest into looting into
vandalism earlier this week so it's a
case by case basis Robin I think that
officials are trying to make sure that
people understand it's certainly safe to
come out here together to try to send
their message as best they can but what
will not be allowed anymore at least the
governor is trying to prevent it from
happening is what we've seen the past
several nights and that's been block by
block lit on fire vandalized and looted
really turning parts of Minneapolis into
unrecognizable areas Robin but has the
message of what happened to George Floyd
been lost
I would answer that question Robin by
saying that for these people the message
for George Floyd has definitely not been
lost and that's why they feel it's even
more incumbent upon them to come out
here today to peacefully protest
together in this way in a very diverse
group because then their message that
George Floyd did not die in vain and
that justice will be served is what
they're trying to send and this is very
much a reaction to not only George
Floyd's death but to the damage we've
seen night in and night out here in
Minneapolis because the people here tell
me that they're afraid that all of that
violence will overshadow what they're
calling a peaceful message so there is a
lot of dissension and anger still in
what happened to George Floyd but the
group of people that I'm gathered
surrounded by today they very much want
to have justice pursued but they want to
separate themselves from that group of
people that have caused so much damage
in this city Robin Morgan Chesky in
Minneapolis tonight thousands marched in
Toronto today in response to the death
of a young black woman regis court in
ski Paquette fell from the balcony of
her apartment while officers were inside
a lawyer for the family says her mother
called 911 because her daughter was in
distress over a family conflict
Morgan Campbell reports thousands of
people gathered at Christie pits Park in
Toronto's Midtown rallying against
indigenous and anti black racism across
North America
we got actual support right there's a
lot of things happening around the world
and we have to make sure we show
solidarity at all times and it's
important that we make sure that we know
that black lives matter Saturday's rally
was sparked by the death of regis
krichinsky poquette's the 29 year old
had fallen from an apartment balcony
Wednesday this happened in my
neighborhood regis krichinsky protects
oh I'm mortified
and I just wanted to do what I could to
help support this the protest wound its
way through city streets leading the way
were members of the cocoa tin Ski
Paquette family her family believes
police played a role in her death the
incident is now being investigated by
Ontario's police watchdog we should keep
our strategy together that's very
important for me in a sense that the
demonstrators are willing to disperse
yet ended their protest here at Toronto
Police Headquarters well over an hour
ago they're still here they're chanting
black lives matter they really want some
answers as to what exactly happened on
that balcony Wednesday however police
are only saying that they respect their
their decision to protest and stand up
for what they believe in Robin gamble in
Toronto coming up finally lifting off
despite the weather concerns the dragon
goes into space
and Canada stand on funding the whu-oh
after an ally pulls out
despite being the hardest-hit bykova 19
the u.s. is severing all ties with the
World Health Organization its primary
rule is to lead the response to global
health issues like the pandemic but
president Trump has been critical of the
organization's handling of the virus and
the u.s. is the biggest financial
supporter so now other countries
including Canada could be asked to fill
the gap here's my clicker tour they have
failed to make the requested and greatly
needed reforms u.s. President Donald
Trump had threatened to sever ties with
the World Health Organization and
withhold funding now it's official we
will be today terminating our
relationship with the World Health
Organization and redirecting those funds
to those funds total five hundred and
fifty million dollars Canadian or
fifteen percent of the wh o--'s overall
budget Canada's annual contribution is
seventeen million dollars now we added
another seventeen and a half million in
response to kovat 19 we could be sending
more money to the WH o and the WH o did
put out a further appeal recently for an
additional one point four billion
dollars and we are considering what an
appropriate response would be so there
is likely to be an additional response
to the WH o but will it fill the gap
that the u.s. is is leaving it not not
just Canada Elam Germany's Health
Minister tweeting the WH o needs reform
adding the EU should engage more
financially it's unclear if European
countries will step up as many countries
including Canada agree that reform will
only come from a post pandemic review of
the WH o--'s response to Coba 19 while
our government isn't commenting directly
on the u.s. s decision to cut ties with
the organization Canada's position is
clear we would rather be part of that
process pushing for more transparency
pushing to have you know a better
stronger response as opposed to taking
ourselves out of the conversation the
President of the European Commission is
also calling for global cooperation and
solidarity while asking the u.s.
reconsider its decision to leave the WH
o
my clue creature global news Ottawa
still ahead the crisis in Hong Kong and
the British offer to its former colony
a handful of Beijing supporters marched
to the US consulate in Hong Kong today
to demonstrate against what they call
American interference yesterday
President Trump said the US would end
preferential economic treatment of Hong
Kong British Prime Minister Boris
Johnson says China's tighter grip on
Hong Kong violates the one country two
systems framework Beijing agreed to that
when it took back the former colony
crystal commencing reports fear over
China's strengthening its grip on Hong
Kong has hit another flashpoint to take
my last breath I will come out and fight
for freedom they are trying to suppress
as much as possible the full scope of
the legislation is not known but world
leaders say it reaches into areas seen
as protected China agreed when in 1997
the UK handed over control of Hong Kong
that for 50 years it would retain a
capitalist economy the justice system
would be maintained as well as human
rights and freedoms as a pressure tactic
millions in Hong Kong with or eligible
for British national overseas passports
could be granted extended UK stays
remove that six-month limit and allow
those being a passport holders to come
to the UK and to apply to work and study
for extendable periods of 12 months and
that would itself provide a pathway to
future citizenship the pandemic quelled
protests but for a year there have been
large and at times violent clashes
between throat um Achra sea groups and
officials the current government is seen
as beholden to China if I can sacrifice
more Hong Kong we do so this is my home
what I have displaced gave me I will
fight on to the last day China claims it
is protecting national security but the
truth is that Hong Kong was secure and
prosperous as a free society the United
States which has been at odds with China
hid the country with new sanctions and
will revoke Hong Kong special status
terms of American trade and travels as
expected China hit back Mei Fong teasing
the spokesperson for the foreign
ministry saying if the u.s. is
determined to harm China's interests
China will take necessary
countermeasures adding no country has
the right to interfere in China's
internal affairs like many political
issues involving China the new security
legislation is being presented
differently chinese state media
interviews talk about the need for the
changes in hong kong and how they're
welcomed that is not the message from
those who risk their safety on the
streets this week
[Applause]
Justin Trudeau is calling for calm and a
path that quote allows for prosperity in
a way that citizens in Hong Kong expects
crystal the Manson Global News London
up next second time's the charm for
historic launch
q but zero ignition this table you're
watching history in the making space X
has become the first private company to
launch humans into orbit two NASA
astronauts are onboard the Falcon 9
rocket marking the first human
spaceflight from the US in nearly a
decade and it almost didn't happen on
Wednesday
bad weather halted the mission 17
minutes before liftoff this time around
it kept down to the last hour it will
take 19 hours for the crew dragon to
reach the International Space Station
NASA reports at least one point one four
million viewers tuned in online to watch
the high stakes launch the company
behind the mission is owned by Elon Musk
the same guy who brought you Tesla and
this mission takes space exploration to
a new level
one rocket launched the u.s. into a
brave new era of space exploration for
the first time a private company SpaceX
did the heavy lifting taking two
American astronauts into orbit veteran
astronauts Doug Hurley and Bob Behnken
taking part in the mission it's safe to
say space travel has never looked like
this before from the designer suits to
the ship itself full of sleek screen
controls the founder of Tesla behind
this venture what today is about is is
reigniting the dream of space and
getting people fired up about the future
the journey of the crew dragon is
intended to restore America's ability to
launch its own astronauts into space
since NASA retired its shuttles in 2011
this is definitely one of the vehicles I
might fly on which is pretty exciting
for me you get to see it fly Canadian
astronaut Jeremy Hansen is waiting on
his own future flight assignment and has
watched NASA's experiment in private
space travel closely does that open up
the doors for more and more frequent
space exploration Oh most definitely
I mean there's no other way to look
in fact you know we we see it as
increasing our ability to do accomplish
our goals from a government as a
government body in space he believes it
opens the door for more frequent space
exploration that includes a return to
the moon and beyond the crew Dragon is
one of several commercial spacecraft
under development in partnership with
NASA all of this ultimately is for a
purpose and that is to get to Mars
everything continuing to look good the
astronauts are headed to the
International Space Station where
they'll spend a few months in orbit
before completing their mission and
they'll return to Earth the same way
they left it onboard that privately
owned spaceship and that is global
national for this Saturday and Robin
Gill tonight your Canada is this rainbow
in northern Saskatchewan thank you for
watching good night
[Music]
you